[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
as the media become unhinged in the era
of Trump the president's most ardent
critics in the media hang on his every
word new cycle after new cycle are all
about Trump and much of this coverage is
negative as journalism lost its purpose
our journalists now nothing more than
ideological advocates
[Music]
crosstalking the media I'm joined by my
guest Charles Hotel in New York he is a
private investor and a writer as well as
host of the podcast show Sunday with
Charles also in New York we have Jo Kang
Jae he is a remedial reporter for the
hill and in Nashville we crossed him
Roger L Simon he is an award-winning
novelist and Academy Award nominated
screenwriter as well as co-founder and
CEO emeritus of PJ Media all right
gentlemen crosstalk rules in fact that
means you can jump in anytime you want
and I always appreciate Joe let me go to
you first here I guess I can pick the
the easiest example the dueling match we
saw with Jim Acosta and President Trump
here I mean what is the state of
journalism and I'm not let like letting
either guy off the hook at least at this
point here but what does that tell us
about journalism today journalism today
I would say has become a matter of many
more opinions being put into reporting
which is leading to mistrust by viewers
and by audiences and Jim Acosta is a
good example of that
Jim openly debates the President on
certain issues he takes aside and then
decides to become the captain of the
debate team during press briefings like
we saw last week it eventually becomes a
confrontation where after every press
briefing whether it be with White House
press secretary Sarah Sanders or with
the President himself the story becomes
Jim Acosta and Donald Trump in terms of
the confrontation in terms of actual
information that may benefit the
American people as far as what the
president is doing his administration is
doing so last week is a perfect example
the president took 68 questions from 35
reporters that's about an average of two
per reporter for whatever reason mr.
Acosta felt he was entitled to ask four
questions and when asked to give up a
microphone when the president wanted to
move on he held on to it like a
three-year-old does a lollipop when you
tell him that it's time to give up the
candy so I think that's the state of
journalism today where we have too many
opinions being injected into actual
reporting and and that's a problem
because you're supposed to report facts
as a White House correspondent and not
offer your feelings up on a particular
topic yeah very well said you know
Charles you know it's CNN says facts
first but I mean CNN now is synonymous
for a brand that says Trump is a liar I
mean that's it I mean I I can't
understand how what few
they have left actually continue to
watch it because I don't care what Trump
is doing every second of the day I
Twitter is more than enough
go ahead Charles yeah I mean that's why
I think the show which is modestly
amusing ancient aliens is getting more
viewers in CNN I mean if you want to
hear anti Trump propaganda you know
where to go if you want to tune into the
White House press briefing you'd like to
see the the many fine journalists and
there are fine journalists in the White
House press corps get a chance to ask
questions and elicit facts we're not
interested in the news those reporters
opinions we're interested in getting
facts and I think I thought journalism's
and I'm not a journalist but I thought
the goal of journalists was to report
facts as news to a wide viewership and I
think increasingly more and more people
are turning turned off to this approach
and that's why they're going to
alternative formats and that's why I
think CNN and MSNBC and others like them
are in serious jeopardy
you know Roger one of the things and I
look at and we've mentioned seeing in an
MSNBC already on this program what I
find exhausting is their moralizing
because there's not very little coverage
on the opiate crisis for example in the
United States which is a every year more
people die
related to this opioid crisis than the
entire number of American servicemen
that died in Vietnam but I know you hear
that sometimes like with Tucker Carlson
and I think he's great at doing that but
you don't hear about these issues here
and it's because I think that the
liberal media is moralized and they
think they're simply better than their a
political opponents certainly they think
they're better than the President of the
United States
and my character am i characterizing it
fairly go ahead Roger oh I think you are
but also there's another factor involved
here and that's the ever-popular money I
mean what these people are trying to do
is attract retrack their audience it's a
very specific audience even though CNN
is failing MSNBC which is almost a clone
CNN is attracting a large audience they
we did CNN at the same thing because a
Costas kind of a war on but but
basically it's the same game what's
really interesting in the whole White
House press corps is who gets to be
there in the first place one of the
reasons things like the opioid crisis
are not mentioned is the people who are
sitting in that room are mostly the same
people who've been sitting in the front
rows since I first went there to write a
screenplay
this is true back in the 80s when I was
given access to that room it was the
same ABC CBS in the same front room and
essentially it's a cartel and the cartel
dictates what what is heard it's the
same as in a lot of countries as in
Russia too
the only certain Authority only certain
companies get to get a seat at the table
okay so let's now flip to the side of
Donald Trump now obviously when you look
at the Acosta Trump collision course
there it's great for clickbait it's
great for everyone to have opinion upon
and I mean it again it's very exhausting
but you know they in a way you know CNN
and Trump they feed off of each other
instead of confrontation it's it's it's
advantageous for both of them because
there's a good number of viewers out
there that just have complete contempt
for Trump and on the other hand complete
contempt for CNN so it's almost like
playing a game here I mean Trump really
gets what's real out of saying that
about CNN and decosta because he knows
his base loves it and it will be played
over and over and over again everywhere
including Fox so I mean there is a very
symbiotic relationship here go ahead Joe
the oldest game in Washington is to
attack unpopular institutions rightie
Republican used to attack the IRS here
Democrat you would attack a Republican
Congress and so on it's it's it's a
mutually beneficial thing with the
President and with CNN for instance or
the meet
in general but it's not just his base
and in other words 93% of Republicans
feel that the media reports knowingly
false information which is a pretty
scary thing it's no longer biased now it
actually some people see it as a
completely intentional act
but then 79% and this is an Axios poll
by the way 79% of independents 8 and 10
basically say the same thing a majority
of Democrats say the same thing so when
the president attacks the media there is
no downside to that yeah in terms of him
doing that but to go back to an earlier
port in terms of the same people being
in the room I have a proposal for this
and I'm actually borrowing this partly
from Ari Fleischer who used to be a
White House press secretary under george
w bush and mike mccurry under president
clinton and that is we got to rotate
different reporters in there on one day
have the president White House press
corps Tuesday bring in business
reporters Thursday or Wednesday the
Foreign Press Thursday may be bloggers
and then Friday everybody gets a
three-day weekend or bring back in the
White House press corps I think you get
a lot more different questions in there
and a lot more questions with substance
and said the sizzle that we're currently
seeing Charles that's a very good idea
here but the cartel I like how Roger
phrases it the cartel would have nothing
to do with it I mean NPR and CNN and
MSNBC they will instantly translate yeah
well you know but again it's it's a pot
it's a power struggle right now I think
Jim Acosta should have had his
credentials suspended because he
misbehaved himself
that's not his house it is not his venue
but Charles the liberal media believe it
is their right to do exactly that that
is the problem well I think what we're
seeing in the marketplace and this is an
immodest plug for our show is a move
towards opinions that are backed up by
sources and every one of our broadcasts
we provide a slideshow for free with
links to the primary sources so you can
validate you know you can test for
yourself whether our views and opinions
make any sense and you can do more work
looking at it there are a number of
alternative sites that do that type of
work and I heard one statistic that
taken as a group more more people are
getting their news from such sites via
YouTube and other platforms then from
the traditional media because the
traditional media is too slow it's too
inaccurate as you point out nobody
trusts it and they keep on falling on
there
faced over and over again but then Roger
I mean okay we to all three of you have
suggested that what the liberal media is
doing is doing now is not working but
Roger why do they keep doing it then I
mean the the statistics are overwhelming
okay I mean just look at the ratings I
mean the cartoon channel is doing well
in comparison go ahead Roger
why don't they address this go ahead
unfortunately I wish it were true
because if the car to travel was winning
every time I take the sitting to CNN so
the world would disappear unfortunately
I think that Trump has done them all a
favor
I mean he's giving them all kinds of
publicity and I see I agree with jobs
proposal I think it's a great one and
Shirin Spicer I when he was the press
secretary was trying to do something
sort of like that but it seems to have
gone by the wayside but you know other
methods have to be taken because in
reality like MSNBC is raking in the
dough just see it in essence as much but
you know Fox is obviously making
tremendous amounts of money so it's not
the system isn't graded yet for real
news unfortunately okay let me go to Joe
before we go to the break here Fox was
mentioned here and their business model
is doing very well is it because they
have it and I thought I'm thinking of
like Hannity oh and Laura Ingraham I
mean they obviously have a pro Trump
agenda I mean it's obvious for anyone to
say but it works Joe yeah on the
editorial side they mostly have a pro
Trump agenda there's plenty of never
Trump errs there too sure I think Fox is
somewhat unpredictable in that sense
like you don't quite know what Shep
Smith or Chris Wallace or Bret Baier the
news side of the organization they do a
solid job the other two channels their
news organizations have now become there
or the news divisions have become
opinion eyes but the reason why Fox does
so well I wish I had a PI with me I
don't so gonna have to draw a circle
here okay split that pie in half Fox
gets that 50% CNN decided let's go after
the other half that MSNBC has in terms
of liberal and they get about 20
and MSNBC gets 30 and that's why they do
well because they have no competition
from the right and CNN decided to give
up the middle so that that's basically
it and they just simply have more talent
and more compelling personalities on
there it's that simple
hold that thought we're gonna go to a
short break gentlemen and after that
short break we'll continue our
discussion discussion on the media in
the era of Trump welcome back to
crosstalk where all things are
considered I'm Peter Lavelle to remind
you we're discussing the media in the
age of Trump
[Music]
okay let me go back to Charles in New
York much like what Joe does I watch a
lot of media it gets more and more
difficult as I as we go through this
administration you know I'm more of an
outsider looking in here but it seems to
me that the Democratic Party has MSNBC
and CNN as their spokespeople it is it
that's the way it looks from here okay
and and then I would even go further I
get the impression during this midterm
cycle that a lot of Democrats watch CNN
and NBC NBC to get their talking points
it's almost a circular thing okay I've
never seen such a large group of
candidates repeat exactly the same thing
sometimes in order okay and I think
there's a lot of viewers in the United
States that have a big problem with that
go ahead Charles yeah I think it was Joe
I've heard him on television mentioned
that one of the big conundrums right now
I was trying to figure out what is the
true split between among Democrat
Republican and independent
I think Democrat Republican share has
fallen a lot and suddenly so what we
you're right what we see here are
Democrat talking points being spewed
forth in a coordinated fashion not just
on CNN and MSNBC but New York Times
sherry treasure and other chances sure
and most of the print print and radio so
I mean instead of focusing right now not
on the Muller investigation but on the
fact that it seems to me that Democrats
are trying to rig not just the election
but the post-election gathering counting
of votes that seems to be a serious
fraud upon the American electorate we're
not spending enough time talking about
that but we have been obsessing for many
months about whether Russia you know
might have purchased some Facebook Ads
you know in modest quantity it could
have had an impact on the 2016 election
integrity of election strikes me as a
very important issue across the entire
political spectrum we should care that
we can know that our votes will be
counted properly and in this high-tech
age we can't have we don't have that
assurance as is being played out right
before our eyes that's a serious scandal
in
I absolutely agree you know Roger it
seems to me one another big problem here
you know I'm a conservative out you know
in all my viewers know that okay so I'm
going to criticize CNN and MSNBC
probably far more than other television
networks but you know it seems to me
that the cultural war that is being
played out the you see it seems to me
that the liberal media is the flagbearer
of that about values about families what
a family is what about immigration the
whole transgender debate I mean if you
look at conservative media and you look
at CNN and MSNBC you see two different
cultural world worlds there and it seems
to me that CNN really pushes that really
hard is that a wise move on their part
because it's what they believe that's my
point that's my point that's my point
they project their values yes well you
know we all do that's the sad truth you
know one of the things that's being
revealed that's positive about all this
if you pay attention is this is what
journalism always was
I mean it's written by human beings and
all human beings are biased let's face
it I'm more on the conservative side as
you are and I think that there's a lot
of silliness and absurdity and the
values being projected by CNN but I'm
glad that we're all it's all out in the
open now because back in the old days I
mean I'm not a young person anymore
I remember Walter Cronkite and we all
believed him religiously but it turns
out back you know if you look back some
of the things he said were dead-on wrong
and probably purposefully but in those
days there was no back and forth really
it was you know it was totally dominated
by three networks that are been
essentially said the same thing and now
there's at least dialogue that's the
improvement in a certain way I'd be
interested to see what Joe said about
that yeah well you know Joe the the
interesting thing here is that again
when I compare the cable station that's
really
for me the issue of omission what is not
discussed for example all of this you
know during the summer with with Russia
gauge heaters struck Peter his
girlfriend Lisa Paige Bruce or and all
that I mean looking at MSNBC and CNN
they just glossed over because the
president is attacking the intelligence
community on Fox well Wow I mean if you
wanted to get all of the details they
did a damn good job and really a superb
job we'll see if that continues with the
new Congress but it's really I see this
as the Mia media coverage of omission of
what is not talked about and what is
crowded out because of how many scoops
of ice cream Donald Trump had go ahead
Joe well yeah I mean you look at one of
the biggest stories that has been
omitted since the president took office
2017 extending into this year and that's
that ninety-eight percent of the
territory controlled by the Isis
Caliphate has been taken back that that
Caliphate has been eviscerated remember
Isis dominated the news in 2015 it
seemed every other week there was some
sort of attack going on in Paris in
London in New York even more recently
now you don't really hear much about
them anymore that's not to say they've
gone away completely there's gonna be
lone wolves of course but I mean that's
a pretty big story I mean this this Isis
was seen as the next al Qaeda except
much more reckless you don't see any
talk about that and as you said it's
like two different galaxies sometimes
when you watch Fox News and CNN and
MSNBC particularly with and was brought
up before the Florida recount where I
could have predicted even before this
happened as far as the recounts that at
CNN and MSNBC would take the side that
there's absolutely nothing wrong going
on in Broward County in Florida and that
Fox would be pursuing more the story in
terms of is there something going wrong
who's responsible in what's going to
happen next so again that's one network
having a real news division and the
other ones just be becoming completely
opinion and predictable opinion at that
because you know why they do this and
I'll leave it here cuz I know you gotta
go fear from their audiences they all
check their Twitter feeds every anchor
I've been on many sets every anchor
every host when they go to commercial
they check to see what the reaction is
and if it's negative they don't know how
to handle it so they want to give
comfort food to the audiences instead of
telling them what they should
here instead of what they want to hear
that is amazing that is so true you know
Charles one thing also Donald Donald
Trump's a racist he's a bigot he's a
misogynist he's a homo a homophobe
everything okay
it seems to me that you know he's acute
and I'm not a big defender of the
president I like some of his policies
some of them I don't like and I always
call balls and strikes okay so let's be
clear about that but you know here we
have CNN MSNBC Washington Post New York
Times and they bring up the issue of
racism and it seems to me it's the left
that is oh they are the dog whistle when
it comes to these issues they're always
pointing them out and I find it really
remarkable that you know okay
Trump said I am a nationalist well I'm a
trained historian okay I know what that
term means I know how it can be used I
know it how could how it can be abused
okay the way Trump said it was perfectly
logical all right fine okay but the dog
whistles come out I have the impression
that people that make these judgment
calls have very little knowledge of
history very little knowledge of the the
the the human these civil rights
struggles that the United States had to
go through and and make great
achievements I must say there are other
challenges here but it seems to me
they're they're very low octane thinkers
when it comes to understanding political
rhetoric because they interpret it
immediately with their own their own
ideological mindset go ahead Charles
especially so and you think about for
the last 30 40 years mainstream academia
the Harvard's the yells etc have been
infected by these professors and their
supporting cast who I think are ignorant
many of them so it's not surprising when
you think about the accusation that
Donald Trump is a racist one of the most
underreported stories and I haven't seen
recent facts on it
is the degree to which Donald Trump's
support among african-americans and
minorities has soared since 2016 yeah
you think about across this great
country Democrats are merchants of
misery they
what tales of woes so you can then rely
on big government you know what how did
the Democrats account for the fact that
an inner city after inner city which
they've controlled in many of these blue
states life has been horrible
until recently under Donald Trump
african-american minority unemployment
is is a low and the number of new
business startups is high confidence is
improving I mean it's a miracle what
he's done as far as I can tell in just
two years so to call him a racist when
you look at his crowd rallies and he
touts those statistics those crowds are
not sitting and you know booing when he
says african-american unemployment is
its historic low they're cheering that
so it's a false a false accusation of my
view Roger you know well I did a program
last week a post-mortem of the the
midterms and we had a democratic
strategist and I asked her you know
what's your takeaway and she said well
we got three Hispanic governors a
lesbian
senator excited and she said their
diversity was wonderful and then I went
to the next guest and I said I thought
the country was all about unity about
coming together here and she had no idea
what I was talking about at all because
I don't care about those attributes I
care about content of character
competence this is what drives me nuts
about the liberal media okay
oh the caravan let's talk about the
caravan or the invasion whatever we talk
about the legality of crossing the u.s.
border illegally that is a simple stuff
guys okay but you don't get that no
racist racist that's all you get
Roger go ahead well you know I am an
actual real live better another civil
rights movement I was heavily in it and
my best friend from grammar school as a
fellow named Andy Goodman was a fella
named Andy Goodman who was shot by the
Klan so I was there and did that I can
tell you that what's going on why
today's direct Democratic Party is the
betrayal of everything we did the day
favor renewed segregation we were
fighting for integration and there's
nothing more despicable to me in my
heart than the current Democratic
Party's race
optics and identity politics it is the
reverse of what was the real intention
of dr. Martin Luther King and I it's
appalled me actually and these idiots in
the media
that continue it are to be ashamed
forever
let me give Joe let me give Joe the last
25 seconds go ahead Joe okay I think it
was brought up before as far as
environment and why are so many media
organizations liberal and it's because
it's all concentrated in New York
Washington where I am in New York for
instance and when you live in that
environment you suddenly begin to
conform to certain ideas into certain
policies and certain perspectives and I
think that's part of the problem that
most of our media that least nationally
that we see are in areas that probably
voted for Hillary Clinton something at a
ninety to ten rate over Donald Trump and
that's part of the problem as well yet
almost all the newsrooms on the each
coasts are exactly the same
all right gentlemen that's all the time
we have many thanks to my guests in New
York and in Nashville and thanks to our
viewers for watching us here at RT see
you next time and remember crosstown
rules
[Music]